[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit hanna
zimmermann und christian sievers
guten abend in einem berliner
breitscheidplatz ein auto rast in eine
menschengruppe auf dem bürgersteig die
nachricht löst entsetzen aus und lässt
alte bilder wieder hochkommen bilder die
wir nie wieder sehen wollten berlin nähe
breitscheidplatz heute vormittag ist es
wieder passiert es gab ein todesopfer es
gibt viele verletzte darunter einige
sehr schwer verletzte und es gibt den
autofahrer der das wird den tag über
immer klarer wohl mit voller absicht
gehandelt hat sylvia bleßmann mit mehr
worte des trostes tiefe trauer stilles
gedenken am abend in der berliner
gedächtniskirche ein ort an dem für
viele berliner die wunden noch nicht
verheilt sind weil hier ganz in der nähe
der kirche schon einmal ein auto 2016 in
eine menge rast und wie heute tot und
fassungslosigkeit hinterließ die
traurige gewissheit des tages eine frau
starb hier am beliebten boulevard als
ein auto in eine gruppe mit vielen
schülern der zehnten klasse aus hessen
raste ihre lehrerin überlebte den
aufprall nicht fünf weitere aus der
gruppe wurden schwer verletzt geborgen
sanitäter und seelsorger waren zügig am
unfallort eine trümmer spur zeigt die
minuten des grauens das tatfahrzeug
steckt in einer schaufensterscheibe
augenzeugen schildern dass der fahrer
erst eine tonne gerammt haben soll dann
wieder auf die straße vor und
schließlich wieder auf den gehweg rast
dann eine querstraße weiter in einem
schaufenster zum stehen gekommen also
tatsächlich eingedrungen wenn das in das
gebäude durch die schaufensterscheibe
wurde dort erst mal festgehalten von
passantinnen und passanten so mein
kenntnisstand und dann von der einsatz
gehabt von uns unmittelbar festgenommen
der 29 jährige deutsch armenier ist in
polizeigewahrsam beamte durchsuchten
zeitnah seine berliner wohnung ein
bekennerschreiben fanden sie nicht alle
sicherheitsbehörden von bund und land
sind im engen austausch betonten
vertreterinnen der berliner politik am
ort des geschehens wir werden jetzt in
alle richtungen natürlich auch den
tatverdächtigen überprüfen derjenige ist
ins krankenhaus gekommen das heißt also
dort auch mit einer entsprechenden
untersuchung natürlich wir haben im
moment nicht einschlägige erkenntnisse
für eine politische tat aber im moment
wir ermitteln nach wie vor unter
hochdruck auch wenn alle verletzten in
kürzester zeit vorbildhaft versorgt
wurden der schock sitzt tief im herzen
von berlin und auch in der hessischen
heimat der betroffenen ich möchte mein
tiefes mitgefühl für die opfer zum
ausdruck bringen für die betroffenen für
ihre angehörigen und unserer gemeinsamen
erschütterung ausdruck darüber verleihen
was hier passiert ist er ist natürlich
eine schockierende nachricht das merkt
man auch im ort ist ein kleiner ort die
leute reagieren sehr betroffen da drauf
das ist was ich im moment sagen kann ob
amokfahrt mit vorsatz oder medizinischer
notfall die ermittlungen vor ort in der
berliner gedächtniskirche hatten bis zur
stunde an
den aktuellen stand bekommen wir zu
unserer rechtsexpertin saar attacke
seiner guten amt was können wir denn
aktuell über die hintergründe sagen
vielleicht zunächst mal zum fahrer der
mutmaßliche täter soll 1993 in armenien
geboren worden sein er soll aber auch
deutscher staatsangehöriger sein und er
soll seit 2008 in berlin gemeldet sein
die ermittler fanden wohl in seinem auto
unter anderem ein plakat mit der
aufschrift stoppt die aggression der
türkei und da er in armenien geboren
wurde und das historische den konflikt
zwischen der türkei und armenien
angeblichen des völkermord- der türkei
mit armenien liegt er denn natürlich die
vermutung nah dass eine politisch
motivierte tat gewesen sein könnte aber
ganz klar muss man sagen der mutmaßliche
täter hat gerade kein türkisches
konsulat angegriffen er hat auch nicht
gezielt eine gruppe türkischstämmiger
menschen angegriffen sondern eine
schülergruppe das war nicht gezielt aus
deswegen kann man aktueller stand nicht
von einer politisch motivierten tat
ausgehen außerdem aktueller stand gibt
es kein manifest kein bekennerschreiben
auch deshalb hat der generalbundesanwalt
bislang die ermittlungen nicht an sich
gezogen jetzt ist ja das ganze in der
nähe oder unmittelbarer nähe des
breitscheidplatz das passiert schon bei
dem namen kommen wieder schlimme
erinnerungen hoch war dieser ort nach
ansicht und nach bisherigen ermittlungen
der polizei gezielt gewählt auch da
sehen die ermittler aktuell keine
parallelen das hat verschiedene gründe
sie sagen sie gehen eher davon aus dass
wir es hier mit jemandem zu tun haben
der eine psychische störung hat und sie
haben auch noch mal zu bedenken gegeben
dass jemand der eine vielzahl von
menschen gezielt töten will alten
geplanten anschlag begeht der nimmt
nicht in kleinwagen seiner schwester
sondern der mietet sich zumindest ein
kleinlaster um gezielt viele menschen zu
töten das heißt die ermittler gehen
aktuell nicht davon aus dass es dort
bedeutende parallelen gibt außerdem
haben sie mir gesagt dass er wegen
verschiedener gewalttaten polizeibekannt
gewesen sein aber nicht den
sicherheitsbehörden als gefährdet das
heißt man hat ja keinen terroranschlag
sehen bekommen sehen ok also es war
offenbar kein unfalls war offenbar nach
dem derzeitigen stand auch kein
terrorakt was was dann genau stand der
ermittlung muss man ganz klar sagen es
sieht danach aus dass dieser mutmaßliche
täter vorsätzlich vorgegangen ist also
kein unten an es sieht auch danach aus
dass er keine politische ideologische
motivation hatte also kein
terroranschlag es sieht vielmehr danach
aus und es spricht viel dafür dass er
eine psychische störung hat dass er
persönliche motive also können wir von
einer amok fahrt ausgehen aber man muss
ganz klar sagen das ist der aktuelle
stand ist noch viel zu früh
abschließende ergebnisse zu haben der
die motivationslage und der tathergang
die werden gerade erst aufgeklärt
schrecklich was auf jeden fall
herzlichen dank seiner attacke heute
abend hier bei uns im studio und im
heute-journal update nachher fragen an
in berlins regierende bürgermeisterin
franziska giffey soviel zunächst zu
diesem thema
die großen zahlen die wir in deutschland
im moment an den tankstellen sehen sind
ja bereits künstlich gedrückt mit
steuergeld genauer mit 3,15 milliarden
steuergeld sie bewegen sich dennoch
schon wieder nach oben dorthin zurück wo
sie mal waren ohne den milliarden
einsatz des staates man kann förmlich
dabei zusehen wie da gerade einiges
verzapft wird denn irgendwo ist das geld
ja geblieben was also kann man tun wenn
der tank rabatt für autofahrer plötzlich
er bei den mineralölkonzernen ankommt
ausgerechnet bei den konzern also wo sie
sowieso gerade mit dollar augen in die
welt gucken in der diskussion ist jetzt
eine sondersteuer für kriegs gewinner so
etwas gab es während der weltkriege etwa
in frankreich und den usa so etwas gibt
es jetzt wieder in italien und
großbritannien macht das sinn und ginge
es auch in deutschland da die handkamera
18 jahren sind dem nachgegangen
die spritpreise sie treiben die
autofahrer zur verzweifeln denn der tank
rabatt von 35 cent pro liter benzin und
knapp 17 cent pro liter diesel verpufft
der tank rabatt war eine schnapsidee
wegen des sabbats steigen jetzt gerade
die profite bei den mineralölkonzern
noch einmal deutlich und es stellt sich
die frage was man dagegen tun denn das
kann ja nicht das ziel der politik
gewesen sein dass man steuergeld
verwendet um es am ende bei den
mineralölkonzernen zu sehen mehr als
drei milliarden euro steuergelder für
einen tank rabatt der bei den
autofahrern kaum ankommt wie kann man
die mineralölkonzerne doch zur kasse
bitten eine idee ist die sogenannte über
geringe steuer eine abgabe auf gewinne
in kriegs- und krisenzeiten diese über
gewinn steuer die solche nur in solchen
fällen angewendet werden so gesehen
wurde hat ein unternehmen eine
verdoppelung oder verdreifachung seiner
gewinne in den letzten monaten erlebt
denn da kann man vernünftigerweise nicht
davon ausgehen dass das irgendetwas mit
innovationen oder unternehmerischer
leistung zu tun gehabt hat das war dann
einfach glück beziehungsweise
krisengewinnler rey und nur für solche
fälle da wird die überwiegend gewinn
steuer tatsächlich anfallen die abgabe
auf kriegs und krisengebiete hat bereits
in den ersten beiden weltkriegen
funktioniert in den vereinigten staaten
aber auch in großbritannien und
frankreich mit den einnahmen
erwirtschafteten die staaten gewinnen
wie es heute funktionieren kann zeigen
uns unseren nachbarn beispiel italien
hier finanziert die über gewinn steuer
auf energiekonzerne zu fast 90 prozent
zuschüsse und tank rabatte für
verbraucher
auch frankreich hat seit april einen
tank rabatt er erfolg bezahlung an der
kasse zudem gibt es energie checks und
eine erhöhung des kilometergeldes
über gewinn steuer ja oder nein ein
thema das auch die koalition spaltet die
fdp will sie nicht die spd sieht darin
einen ausweg man kann das angehen
antreten haben es gemacht und das sind
jetzt auch länder sozusagen aus der
europäischen union die das umgesetzt
haben man muss wie gesagt genau auf die
auf die branche zu gehen wenn es
betrifft sollte nicht in ganz
deutschland gelten sondern die branche
betreffen die wirklich von dieser
situation jetzt maßlos profitieren und
dann muss es genau ausgestaltet werden
gewinner sollen unternehmen und trotzdem
machen das ist ein work wirtschaft so es
geht darum diese übung gewinne als ich
diesen schamlosen gewinner aus den
krisen situation als die heraus zu
besteuerung eine über gewinn steuer auf
mineralölkonzerne alleine ist allerdings
hierzulande nicht so leicht umzusetzen
kritiker berufen sich auf den grundsatz
der gleichbehandlung heißt eine branche
allein darf besteuert werden hinzu kommt
die mineralölkonzerne sind gesetzlich
nicht verpflichtet rabatte an den
verbraucher weiterzugeben das
bundeskartellamt eigentlich
kontrollinstanz für die preise bleibt
seit wochen waage der sehen seitdem
ukraine krieg hier eine entkopplung mit
anderen worten teilweise gesehen dass
der hohe ölpreis runtergegangen ist
tankstellenpreise sind dem aber nicht im
selben maß gefolgt dass es exakt der
grund dafür dass wir diese untersuchung
auch auf raffinerie ebene machen um am
ende eben die raffinerie preise und die
tankstellenpreise in bezug zueinander
setzen zu können es wird also weiter
untersucht der tank rabatt nach wenigen
tagen schon ein hoher kopierer und ein
erneuter stresstest für die koalition
viel diskussion also um eine energieform
die eigentlich längst auslaufmodell sein
sollte und gleichzeitig ist das ganze
zeichen dafür wie wir die
herausforderungen gerade doppelt und
dreifach zu meistern haben die zukunft
hat es auch nicht leicht wenn der wind
unsere energie liefern soll dann müssen
wir windräder bauen und zwar in bisher
ungekanntem ausmaß so weit ist dass
allen klar was aber ist mit
abstandsregeln was ist mit dem
naturschutz immer deutlicher wird jetzt
das alles zusammen kaum funktionieren
wird die bundesregierung jedenfalls will
mit einem ganzen gesetzespaket die
hürden für den bau von windrädern
einreißen und verpflichtende ziele
festlegen bernd weltin
am horizont rotieren sie schon näher
aber sollen sie nicht kommen leonard
schuster kämpft gegen neue windräder in
seiner heimat rohrlack in brandenburg
wenn die 250 meter hoch werden werden
sie wahrscheinlich doppelt so laut dann
wird das noch mal ein anderer
geräuschpegel sein dass nicht im
wahlkampf im vergangenen jahr stritt
sich schuster noch mit der grünen
kanzlerkandidaten in der zdf sendung
klartext zu groß zu nahe zu laut seien
die windräder was die inzwischen
gewählte regierung jetzt plant ist für
schuster ein albtraum
naturschutzrecht wird aufgeweicht
gesundheitsrecht wird aufgeweicht und
den erneuerbaren energien wird jeglicher
raum gewährt beim windkraftausbau will
die regierung tatsächlich tempo machen
bis 2026 sollen 1,4 prozent der bundes
fläche für windräder nutzbar sein bis
2032 2 prozent
wenn ein bundesland sein festgelegtes
flächen ziel verfehlt gibt es
konsequenzen dann gelten die
mindestabstände zu wohnhäusern nicht
mehr der bund könnte die länder also
zwingen weniger abstände für mehr ausbau
wir haben das schlecht genug gemacht in
der vergangenheit und deswegen war es
die aufgabe meines ministeriums dafür zu
sorgen dass wir jetzt nicht nur die
förderung des eeg vernünftig hinbekommen
sondern auch eine flächen verteilung in
bekommen haben wird gerade in jordanien
für neue energie partnerschaften zu
hause aber erwartet ihn der ärger des
ampel partners fdp ich kann das
bundesministerium nicht verstehen es
bewegt sich damit mit der vorlage nicht
auf dem boden des koalitionsvertrages
und zweitens ist für uns als fdp auch
wichtig dass diese frage vor ort
entschieden wird vor ort entscheiden das
hieße dass jedes bundesland weiter die
abstände komplett alleine regeln darf
auch wenn das den ausbau blockiert der
bund solle sich da raushalten hört man
heute aus sachsen und bayern wir haben
hier im freistaat sachsen einen
gesellschaftlichen frieden erzeugt mit
einer regelung 1000 meter abstand von
der wohnbebauung andere bundesländer
haben das auch und das halte ich auch
für richtig und ich finde eine
bundesregierung die weit weg ist in
berlin sollte sich ein stück weit auch
darauf verlassen wie die menschen vor
ort die dinge sehen ich bin mir auch
sicher dass der bund am ende sich
scheuen wird am ende standorte für räder
auszusprechen das ist eine ganz klare
aufgabe der kommunalen familie
auch das verhältnis tierschutz versus
windkraft soll neu justiert werden zum
beispiel könnten anlagen bald in
landschaftsschutzgebieten gebaut werden
naturschützer prognostizieren eine
klagewelle halb warnend halb thront wir
sehen das risiko dass unglaublich viel
dann doch vor gericht ausgetragen werden
muss und dass am ende die beschleunigung
die wir dringend beim windkraftausbau
brauchen gar nicht eintritt
habe ich betont man könne nicht nur
abstrakt für die energiewende für
energie unabhängigkeit sein man müsse
das auch praktisch umsetzen seine
parteifreundin berbalk war übrigens vor
kurzem wie vereinbart zu gast bei herrn
schuster in rohrlack einig auseinander
gegangen ist man aber nicht
und wir hatten noch für den moment beim
thema mit johanna christian das
eu-parlament will den verkauf von
neuwagen mit verbrenner motor ab 2035
verbieten dafür stimmte heute eine
mehrheit der abgeordneten bevor die
regelung in kraft tritt muss das
parlament allerdings noch mit den eu
staaten verhandeln ein anderer wichtiger
teil des eu klimapakets scheiterte
dagegen heute in straßburg nämlich die
reform des emissionshandels zudem wurden
abstimmungen verschoben zum beispiel zum
sozialen klima fonds für
einkommensschwache haushalte
das klimapaket hat das ziel dass die eu
bis 2050 klimaneutral wird
mit blick auf mögliche corona
infektionswellen im herbst und winter
hat der expertenrat der bundesregierung
von bund und ländern eine
vorausschauende vorbereitung mit kurzen
reaktionszeiten gefordert die
expertinnen und experten drängten auf
eine neue impf und booster kampagne das
rechtzeitige wieder einführen einer
masken pflicht könnte als schnelles
instrumente infektionskontrolle die dann
so das gremium zudem sei eine bessere
datengrundlage nötig um genauere
prognosen treffen zu können
norwegen hat 22 panzerhaubitzen des typs
m 1 9 an die ukraine geliefert das
erklärte das norwegische
verteidigungsministerium aus
sicherheitsgründen sei die lieferung
vorher nicht angekündigt worden die
ausbildung der ukrainischen soldaten an
den waffen habe in deutschland
stattgefunden
die bundesregierung hat angekündigt
sieben panzerhaubitzen 2000 zu liefern
bundeskanzler scholz hat dem
ukrainischen präsidenten sie lenski in
einem telefonat erneut deutsche
unterstützung zugesagt außerdem ging es
in dem gespräch darum wie
getreideexporte auf dem seeweg
ermöglicht werden könnten währenddessen
ist in der osten im osten der ukraine
weiter stark gekämpft worden der
gouverneur der region lohans befürchte
die stadt jiegu donetzk vorerst aufgeben
zu müssen und um die uhr würden ziele im
donbass von russischen truppen
bombardiert
es gerade schon kurz gehört wenn sich
der türkische außenminister heute mit
seinem russischen amtskollegen trifft
dann geht es um einen getreide korridor
für die welt das klingt nach einer
existenziellen frage das ist es auch in
der ukraine lagern zurzeit 23 millionen
tonnen getreide 13 prozent der
weltweiten weizenexporte kamen zuletzt
jedes jahr aus der ukraine
für länder wie somalia die immer wieder
von schweren hungersnöten betroffen sind
sind die folgen eine katastrophe fast
der gesamte weizen der in somalia
verkauft wird stammt aus russland und
der ukraine
und so schätzt das
welternährungsprogramm der uno dass je
nach dauer des krieges weltweit zwischen
33 und 47 millionen menschen zusätzlich
unter hunger und armut leiden werden
seit russlands marine den gesamten
export der ukraine über das schwarze
meer blockiert und das getreide deshalb
im silo verschimmelt sucht die welt nach
einem ausweg aus der türkei gewarnt
man kennt sich man schätzt sich mein
freund sergej nennt außenminister
davutoglu seinen russischen kollegen
business as usual wären 1000 kilometer
weiter nördlich russische panzer und
raketen versuchen den nachbarn ukraine
von der landkarte zu bomben die
dringendste frage des treffens wie kann
so schnell wie möglich weizen aus
ukrainischen helfen sicher exportiert
werden darauf spielt zunächst das
problem zynisch herunter ukrainisches
getreide ist doch nur ein prozent des
weltmarktes peanuts hungerkrise alles
vom westen aufgebauschte propaganda dann
routiniert die übliche schuldzuweisung
wir haben von unserer seite nie eine
lösung dieses kleinen problems behindert
die ukraine muss nur die minen in ihren
häfen räumen und sicherem geleit
korridor und zustimmen
was lavrov nicht erwähnt sind die
russischen kriegsschiffe die die
ukrainische schwarzmeerküste abgeriegelt
haben und von dort ihre raketen abfeuern
eine rasche lösung für die getreide
lieferungen das schwant auch dem
türkischen vermittler ist nicht in sicht
zunächst müsse man beide seiten erst
einmal an den verhandlungstisch bringen
sagt schaaf
natürlich müssen sowohl russland als
auch die ukraine einer solchen
initiative zustimmen wir laden beide ein
nach istanbul zu kommen um das zu
verhandeln die technischen details einer
vereinbarung sollten möglichst schnell
vorab geklärt werden
empfangen wurde lavrov nicht wie
angekündigt im außenministerium sondern
im präsidial palast in ankara dass er
auch mit staatschef erdogan zusammentraf
wurde nicht bestätigt darf aber vermutet
werden die türkei will die nähe zu
russland zum eigenen vorteil nutzen
beispielsweise bei möglichen neuen
türkischen offensiven in syrien ein
klein wenig kam der kreml diplomat zum
schluss dann doch noch aus dem tritt als
ein ukrainischer journalistin fragte was
russland dennoch so alles in der ukraine
stehlen wolle aus rege treiben da wurde
ja viel diplomatischer
die ukraine denkt auch immer nur daran
was ihr wohl spielen könnt und dann
glaubt ihr alle anderen seien genauso
dann war die irritation schon vorbei so
viel ungefilterte kritik ist man im
gleichgeschalteten moskau schon lange
nicht mehr gewohnt
lieferengpässe nadelöhre staus auf den
weltmeeren damit machst du jetzt weiter
gibt stau in der nordsee vor den häfen
deutschlands belgiens und der
niederlande stecken die containerschiffe
fest und die situation dürfte sich ab
morgen sogar noch verschärfen stephanie
beckert in frankfurt was sind dann die
genauen gründe die welle verspätete
frachtschiffe aus china trifft nun auch
noch zu alledem mitten in einen
tarifkonflikt der hafenwirtschaft denn
erstmals seit jahrzehnten hat die
gewerkschaft verdi morgen nachmittag
12.000 hafenarbeiter aus deutschlands
großen sehhilfen zu warnstreiks
aufgerufen das wird zwangsläufig die
abfertigung von 150000
standardcontainern die allein in hamburg
und bremerhaven warten weiter verzögern
mit zusatzschichten und überstunden sind
hafenarbeiter bereits in den vergangenen
monaten an ihre belastungsgrenzen
gegangen um die container lawine zu
bewältigen für sie fordert verdi nun
gehaltserhöhungen von bis zu 14 prozent
doch das personalproblem ist nur ein
faktor in diesem bündel von gesamt
logistischen herausforderungen in den
hafen quillen die lagerflächen über weil
unternehmen ihre container nicht abholen
früher blieben sie zwei bis drei tage
vor dem weitertransport im hafen nun
sind es sechs bis sieben zudem bremsen
engpässe im güterverkehr der bahn sowie
bei spediteuren und verlagern wann der
stau aufgelöst sein wird das konnte uns
heute keiner der akteure sagen es wird
also noch dauern und vor allem kosten
hier in frankfurt bewegte heute die
frage nach der zinswende am vorabend der
ezb sitzung morgen amsterdam hielten
sich anleger zurück das deutsche
börsenbarometer verliert 1 3 43 prozent
von der ezb erwartet man einen klaren
plan der die baldige zinsschritte
erklärt danke stefan ihn nach frankfurt
auch mehr als drei jahrzehnte nach der
wiedervereinigung gibt es kaum
ostdeutsche in spitzenpositionen das
zeigt eine neue studie in zusammenarbeit
mit der universität leipzig bundesweit
liegt der anteil ostdeutscher in den
topjobs von politik wirtschaft justiz
oder universitäten bei nur 3,5 prozent
in ostdeutschland selbst sind es 26
prozent
der ostbeauftragte der bundesregierung
schneider sagte dass sich dies ändern
müsse
die letzte freie trainerstelle in der
bundesliga ist nun auch besetzt enrico
maaßen wird neuer trainer des fc
augsburg
der 38 jährige hatte in den vergangenen
zwei spielzeiten erfolgreich die u23 von
borussia dortmund betreut augsburg hat
mit maßen seinen wunschkandidaten
verpflichtet er folgt auf markus mein
ziel zu den lottozahlen an diesem
mittwoch die lauten
14 11 33 34 48 superzahl 1 alle angaben
wie immer ohne gewähr
so können wir den einen 17 jahre lang
präsident des welt fußballs einer der
mächtigsten sportfunktionäre der welt
ausgestattet mit enormem
selbstbewusstsein
so kennen wir den anderen legendären
nummer 10 der französischen nationalelf
weltklassespieler und dann uefa-chef
seit heute stehen beide sepp blatter und
michel platini vor gericht in der
schweiz es geht um eine dubiose
millionenzahlung den vorwurf des betrugs
um einen fall der die ära blatter bei
der fifa mit einem paukenschlag beendete
es geht aber auch um die rolle der fifa
selbst und um ihren aktuellen
präsidenten sarah tucker berichtet
mächtig reich
einflussreich sehr blatter und michel
platini über jahrzehnte waren sie die
herrscher des weltfußballs waren beste
freunde jetzt sind sie alles los ihre
macht ihre freundschaft und auf dem
spiel steht seit heute auch ihre
freiheit denn sie sind angeklagt hier
vor dem schweizer bundesstrafgericht in
bellinzona
ich bin guter laune
ich bin mir auch bewusst
dass ich nicht so etwas
eben strafbar gemacht habe ich nicht
gemacht das sieht die schweizer justiz
anders sie wirft blatter und platini
laut dieser anklageschrift die dem zdf
vorliegt unter anderem betrug und
urkundenfälschung vor konkret 2011 soll
der damalige fifa chef blatter eine 2
millionen schweizer franken zahlung an
den damaligen uefa-chef platini
genehmigt haben offiziell eine mündlich
vereinbarte restzahlung einer
beratertätigkeit platinis von 98 bis
2012 warum die millionen gezahlt wurden
und wie die ermittler davon erfuhren
genau das soll hier in den kommenden
zwei wochen geklärt werden
ich halte diese strafverfahren für
historisch weil zum ersten mal in dieser
preisklasse von größen des
internationalen fußballs nicht nur
ermittelt worden ist sondern dass auch
tatsächlich zu einer anklage und jetzt
zu einer hauptverhandlung kommt vorwürfe
gibt es aber nicht nur gegen die beiden
angeklagten fußball funktionäre sondern
auch gegen die schweizer justiz denn
anstatt korruption im fußball
aufzuklären endeten schweizer
ermittlungen bislang in einem eigenen
sumpf aus pannen verjährung und affären
zuletzt musste sogar der oberste
straftäter der schweiz zurücktreten
unter diesem gesichtspunkt
denke ich dass das verfahren in der
schweiz jetzt sehr ernsthaft betrieben
wird weil man sieht auch aus perspektive
der schweiz dass man unter
internationaler beobachtung steht und
dass der hauch eines zweifels der sich
auf die neutralität der schweizer justiz
gelegt hat jetzt ausgeräumt werden muss
durch ein gutes verfahren und durch ein
klares urteil heute jedenfalls hat sehr
platter aus gesundheitlichen gründen
nicht ausgesagt morgen sollen nun beide
angeklagten gehört werden das urteil
wird in einem monat erwartet für die
schweizer justiz gilt es da zu zeigen
sie auch ein strafverfahren im fußball
sauber und neutral bis zu ende führen
kann
ja genau in einem monat soll das
abkommen am 8 juli das war unsere welt
an diesem 8 juni danke dass sie dabei
waren und im auslandsjournal gleich nach
uns ein schlüsselloch blick in die
blackbox nordkorea und auf die korona
krise dort die ein volk ohne impfung
überrollt morgen sind an dieser stelle
marietta slomka und heinz was sie da für
sie da wir wünschen ihnen jetzt einen
angenehmen abend
[Musik]
guten abend bis morgen abend überquert
eine kaltfront von tief nana deutschland
von west nach ost dabei gibt es am
alpenrand dauerregen und dieser
dauerregen setzt schon heute nacht ein
sonst wird auch etwas regen aber nicht
so heftiger die temperaturen sinken in
dieser nacht auf 15 grad in der
uckermark und bis 8 grad an der mosel
und steigen morgen in brandenburg und
richtung lausitz auf 22 bis 24 grad
sonst bleibt es kälter vor allen dingen
am alpenrand da werden nur 14 bis 16
grad erreicht und das liegt dort am
dauerregen der nun langsam nachlässt
sonst wird das ein ganz freundlicher
donnerstag sie werden ab und zu die
sonne zu gesicht bekommen ab und zu gibt
allerdings auch regen schauer oder kurze
gewitter am freitag kann es ostbayern
noch etwas regnen danach aber setzt sich
auch dort die sonne durch und die
temperaturen am sonntag steigen auf 19
bis 31 grad es wird also heiß
vielleicht haben sie das heute schon
mitbekommen es ist welttag der ozeane
ozeane brauchen unsere aufmerksamkeit
denn die unterwasserwelt ist in gefahr
nicht mal zehn prozent der meere sind
weltweit bislang geschützt bis 2030
sollen es 30 prozent werden auch um die
artenvielfalt zu erhalten schleppnetze
zum fisch fangen dürfen dann nicht mehr
über jeden meeresboden gezogen werden
sondern nur noch über schlick und sand
für die nord und ost gelten die strengen
regeln ebenfalls nur auf diese weise
dürfen plattfische wie die schule und
krabben weiter gefangen werden was
passiert wenn die natur aus den tiefen
des meeres zurückschlägt erzählt 2023
der schwarm die spektakuläre serie hier
im zdf schon gleich zeigen wir ihnen wie
klimawandel und plastikmüll die meere
bedrohen während der langen nacht der
ozeane guten abend